this past weekend welcome July 24th
[Music]
we're out here
little bit of Einstein a little bit of
Dexter we got everybody out here today
what's up guys welcome to this past
weekend I'm Theo von it is
Monday July 24th July 24th that means
that August is coming on August is
coming on fast you know quickly I don't
if you ever seen those relay races where
it's the Olympics you know and it's
usually the long-distance relay or
something and they got some white team
is winning from finlander you know some
snow land you know from some one of
those snow you know what you know one of
those cultures that lives in those snow
villages you know in America we get out
these snow villages and these snow
globes people put them out around
Christmas and the holidays but they have
a family they have a team I'm sorry
that's winning the Olympic race but then
suddenly boy a couple of little more
tinted skin might be a brother might be
a mixed man somebody comes running
around the bend at the end and and
closes in on you fast and that's autumn
right now let's fall autumn almost upon
us for some I guess I mean I guess like
in Michigan and stuff you guys are I
mean are is Olga still summer you
folding it up I don't know I live in Los
Angeles there's no seasons here you can
wear one dirty t-shirt you know you
don't have to there's no commitment you
enough to do anything in Los Angeles you
can just be here
and just just scream about one world and
everybody is the same and everybody's
good and never you know face any of the
realities that are going on out in the
world you can do that here but I know
that that's not the truth I know that
autumn is coming fall is coming for some
people you know and uh and that's the
reality good to be here guys I'm happy
to be here man I you know I had a good
weekend I didn't get into a ton of stuff
you know I didn't get into the news the
Trump Trump jr. trumple Stiltskin
somebody took a Trump in my yard bro
it's like the news honestly it's like
the news has Asperger's and they start
flopping off you know when I was growing
up they had this boy in my neighborhood
and they called him one love that was
his name and he was mentally handicapped
and they called him one love and and he
would just stand by his house by the
porch and all day he just yelled uh one
more day I can't wait that's what he
said one more day I can't wait and
that's all he said man that's all he
ever said there was a couple of months
where he recited a few Aerosmith lyrics
and I don't know what got into him I
think that was around when Aerosmith and
Guns and Roses were touring together so
he might have caught some of the
excitement you know even through his
disability some of the excitement might
have found its way through it through
his disability into his brain and into
his livelihood and I remember that was a
beautiful time you know um you know when
he would set off a little bit of dude
looks like a lady you know and that was
you know got everybody in the
neighborhood kind of fired up but one
love uh you know he had that Asperger's
he had something you know he had a
little bit of you know he had something
he was caught hard you know he was
caught hard by by the elements you know
he's one of God's favorites they call
him sometimes people that have some
disabilities and a beautiful boy you
know and I think the daddy had left him
and so it was just uh I think it was
maybe his mother and his grandmother
raising them but anyhow he had that and
that's what I think of the news today
it's Asperger's it is 24 hours a day
Asperger's they have just got to the
point where they don't have any brain
left or very little brain and they're
just yelling the same things over and
over again whether you believe things
are saying or not it's just ridiculous
it's Asperger's at this point and that's
why I think the only safe places to get
your news anymore
or from dreams rumors hearsay smoke
signals and Ouija boards homemade Ouija
boards - not the store-bought ones
because those are commercialized and who
knows who's behind them probably Nike
okay but yes I'm staying out of the news
what else am i doing dude let me look
here oh I did see one thing in the news
about USA Today had an article okay
USA Today had an article where people
were complaining about the lack of women
and no lead actors of color in Dunkirk
and Dunkirk is a film that's out right
now Dunkirk it's amazing and guess what
I'm sorry but there's white people in it
it's a story about how white people
attack some other white people and then
those white people were beating them up
and then some good white people came and
rescued those white original white
people you know and I just want to
apologize I think on a national basis
for being an adult white male it is I
know
it's we're not allowed to be that
anymore and I'm sorry I mean it'll
probably only be another 50 years that
I'll be alive so you want to sort of
bear with me bear with me humanity you
know and I'm all about equality yeah but
I don't like forced film casting and I
like it you know because I honestly I
never got never got over black Annie I
never got over black Annie I don't you
seen Annie the first one and it was okay
black Annie nobody liked it even black
people were like why do we have to be
black Annie I just don't like it man
what's next you know what's next are we
going to do a above the rim with white
people or Vietnamese people you know I
mean if we're going to be you know if
we're going to do it then let's do it
but a song I mean you can't dunkirk
amazing movie if you haven't seen it
best movie I've seen since uh Shawshank
Redemption and that's when Andy Dufresne
sneaks through the [ __ ] pipe and catches
his freedom that he is well deserved of
and Brooks was here but anyhow I just
can't stand I just can't believe this
you know done Kurt's an amazing film
check it out but this this article USA
Today complaining about lack of wimp
where you going to put I mean there were
some women there were nurses there were
these men's mothers that were behind
them that that you could tell they
wanted to get home to see their mothers
and wives there were women there in
spirit I don't see a ton of men in the
movie a girls trip you know but I'm in
complaining about it no because that's
fine just God come on you know next
thing they'll be complaint if you're not
if you don't have a woman trapped inside
of your body if you're not transgender
if you don't have you know then they're
going to people going to be complaining
people are going to meet you on the
street like all come up where you don't
have a woman trapped inside of you
what's going on with you boy I mean it's
just ridiculous and that's why I say
about the news man it's Asperger's you
think anybody really believes this no
that's the thing and they get me to talk
about it they get me to think about it
and fired up you know but they can only
fool you for so long with the news they
can only fool you for so long
you know I mean at a certain point it's
almost nice to know that the news is
just [ __ ] you know that it's just
not real anymore that it's it's finally
you realize that it's not good for you
you know you just realize that it's not
even adding value to your life which I
think that's what the news used to do is
have an added value and if something's
not adding value I mean that's when it's
time to let it go but anyhow I can't
see Dunkirk - you know starring a
Charlize Theron and Lena Dunham you know
can't wait to see it dude when they get
attacked by a group of transgender
aliens
fortunately they get rescued by Ezekiel
Elliott and and who else Catwoman
whoever Catwoman is so look forward to
that sequel Dunkirk - what else man I've
been working out a little bit I'm in
pain I don't have you ever been in that
much pain
bad pain getting older pain this all of
a sudden that sounds like one of those
commercials that you hear on the podcast
man I've been in pain recently if you've
been in pain oh you know what helps me
on pain arm pain dot-com slash Theo no I
thought I was in shape that's what I'm
starting to realize I thought I was in
shape you know if you do I thought it
was at least I thought I was a shape if
you depict a shape and said well what
shape are you I would have named a shape
oh I'm a triangle you know where I'm a a
lexicon you know or I'm not tagging it
but now I don't even know if I'm in a
shape anymore I feel like I'm just sort
of something that's kind of piecemeal
you know just don't have a lot of shape
going on to me at this point you know
I've been in a lot of pain my legs I've
been having a seen a trainer beautiful
young lady named Molly great trainer and
a good friend and she has sweetheart she
works with me she's very supportive
which is what your trainer should be you
know they should just be able they
should be they should be supportive I
feel but man I mean muscles I apparently
have a muscle going from like my ankle
to my nuts bra because every time I kind
of turn my knee out a little bit you can
feel a pull kind of a you know an ankle
to nut sort of that whole
Transcontinental Railroad right there
you can hear it you can hear it almost
tighten up like if I hold a violin stick
across the inside of my leg at that
point I mean I might just might just
Beethoven yeah you know what I'm saying
I might just
with that Brahms Lullaby what else man
how to date this weekend I hate you with
a sensual update still been struggling
there with the dark arts on my end you
know and some of you guys know if you're
a longtime listeners that I've you know
often dealt back and forth with um you
know dealing with masturbatory
activities and you know falling victim
to the habit of pornography and yeah you
know and I've still I hit some I hit
some turmoil there I don't want it
anymore you know but I still find myself
doing it and at that point is for me
it's not a good habit for me it's just
not a good habit at that point you know
and it's not really a habit anymore at
that point it's coming something beyond
that because I have it maybe it's
something you could go do to enjoy
yourself it can be positive but I guess
you can have a bad habit and I guess
against maybe that's what it's become is
just a bad habit but I like to stay out
of it you know in the internet they keep
making more pornography like what has to
happen to have made enough you know what
I'm saying to somebody it's almost like
they just need to you know you need to
have a couple like a you know a couple
of naked dudes driving a truck with a
big you know [ __ ] on the front of it and
then just have like a huge orifice in
the middle of the street and then just
drive it into it at top speed kind of
like I'm back to the future and
something side of the clock tower and
the whole reaction and then pornography
breaks down but I I get caught up there
man you know I get caught up there
sometimes falling into it and then that
kind of kills some of my libido and
makes me not present when I'm involved
with real humans so not to get to
interpersonal right there but that's
just you know part of what's going on
but yeah had a little bit of a date this
weekend and it was nice man I got some
feelings you know found myself getting
some feelings and I got nervous too
about having feelings and so I was
thinking a lot about that you know about
if somebody if I feel somebody
cares about me with how do I feel them
and I started to realize that I don't
really know what it's what it's like to
let someone care about me you know I
don't know how to do it you know when
someone usually talks about how they
care about me it's almost like I can't
even hear them and I know this some of
you guys this is going to sound crazy
you're like well I don't know what
you're talking about and that's fine you
know I'm not trying to explain
everybody's point of view this is just
for me and I can hear what they're
saying
vert audio audio Blee but something
inside of me shuts off where I can't
feel what they're saying as they say it
so it's like I can't hear them and feel
what they're saying at the same time if
that makes any sense
like if someone expresses care for me I
don't really know how to take it in you
know and it's something that I think I
got to get to the bottom of if I'm going
to be in a comfortable relationship
environment you know and I wish I could
explain it a little bit better than that
but I just realized that I realized that
I don't know I don't know how to be
cared for by somebody you know I just
don't know how because someone tells me
they care I can't feel them while I'm
listening I can't feel and listen at the
same time it's almost like I can't feel
cared for you know I can recognize when
somebody cares but I can't feel it
very well at all I can think back later
on it myself and feel it some but I
can't feel it in the moment and I'm not
trying to be a debbie downer you know
but I like to check in with you guys and
let you know what's going on with me and
some of the stuff people say well that's
kind of a sad daughter your well that's
not sad really no I don't think
something's sad just because it's real
you know I think what's real is what's
what's most important you know or I try
to make that the case in my life you
know but yeah I mean I'm just trying to
be on the level with you guys we get a
lot of callers here that put you know
put some of their feelings and thoughts
out there and so I don't want to be not
contributing in
that regard you know I want to have some
skin in the game but yeah I just notice
that man if somebody cares about me it's
hard for me to to actually feel that
care it's like my sensors are a little
bit off I can't explain it 100% but I
can explain it as much percent as I just
explained it that's for dang sure guys
we got some good calls we got Tom a man
calling in about keeping my nuts you
know I talked about donating my nuts to
science or charity or you know part of
my body is a meal to a foreign country
because it's hard sometimes to know
people are starving to know that you're
carrying around physical items on your
body or pieces of yourself that you
don't think you even are benefiting the
most from and you feel like that they
would almost be better served as a meal
and another sounds crazy but if we'd all
just been on a plane crash right now and
I'm the one serving my nuts to somebody
I bet you would all be standing in line
okay so don't don't say somebody's nuts
just because well literally here but
don't say somebody's crazy just because
they're hypothesizing something based
off of reality and serious feelings
outside of that I got a couple of colors
that called in about um issues on
Greyhound buses we've all been there
you know I had a man take me behind a
build and said he wanted to show me some
artwork and it was [ __ ] and that was it
a Greyhound bus down there in Gulfport
Mississippi had another dude who filled
a gun with cocaine and said he was going
to blow his brains out shoot himself
right in the up the nostril but the gun
full of cocaine and a bullet have no
idea what happened to that guy literally
he got off this Greyhound never saw that
man again we got another call about a
relationship we got another call about
somebody sitting in a sauna with someone
else who was spraying out and we're
going to get into those calls right now
first I want to tell you some dates
this coming Saturday I'll be in Montreal
July 29th 10 p.m. at club soda that's
where I'm performing I'm hoping to also
get on the show with Ari Shaffir but I
don't know that yet August 10th through
13th Dallas come show some love if
you're even close at the Addison improv
okay
September 21st through 24th I met
hilarities in Cleveland so come see that
nasty September 6th through the 9th I'm
at cap city in Austin Texas you can come
see that and there's a rumor that
huntsville alabama is going to be on the
schedule and there's also a rumor that
in late August we're gonna have a date
in Vancouver I'm trying to find a
theater that seats about 50 small
theatres it's my first time there if you
know one please hit me up and recommend
it also this week on allegedly the
Hollywood podcast that I do with my
co-host Matthew Cole Weiss
we have james Van Der Beek and a lot of
women pleasured themselves and had
posters and drawings and him up in their
lives when they were young we got him in
and so we're excited about that
you know him from Dawson's Creek and
he's also playing Diplo in a new project
on Vice land so you can check that out
and we are excited to have that man
coming in the studio so he's on there
and that will go up Tuesday this Tuesday
the 25th okay man I think that brings us
to everything is you can see if you're
on YouTube right now you can see that to
keep in my squad hydrated print that's
right behind me beautiful prints you can
get those online Theo van comm slash
store I've got this beautiful picture of
Chris Farley right here who died of
overdose very sad one of the funniest
ever one of the funniest ever but I
appreciate you guys calling in man yeah
that's kind of all that went on this
weekend you know that was hit am I've
just been rolling my legs that I had to
use this leg roller because I've been in
so much pain just not realizing that
suddenly I am getting older you know
that my body is just it's not a
wonderland anymore you know it's kind of
like a local fare it's like a local
small town carnival where there's people
in the back smoking cigarettes and you
know hiding dope and potted plants and
and stealing from children things like
that stealing [ __ ] out of your car while
you're out there playing games at the
shoot-'em-up duck game so it's more of a
my body's a wonderland
and now it's more of my body is a local
fair or even a just a school fair where
the best thing to have is some jump
house and some confetti eggs and it's at
one chance for people to throw confetti
eggs at that shitty teacher that they
have did you ever have that fair I did
alright guys let's get to some calls man
I really appreciate it I had some great
ones last week and this is a [ __ ] this
is kind of a follow up one that's been
going on
this calls been kind of this topic has
been going on a little bit and let's get
into it here we go hey what's up feel my
name is Clinton and I love your podcasts
dude I just calling about cutting your
balls off and everything is you clinton
here calling about cutting my balls off
oh we're clinton I totally understand
and the focus it could be acquired if
you lose those balls and stop worrying
about jizz and all over boobs and stuff
but I got a little experience with that
I was on the möbius for a while one
thing that okay and this is Clinton on
opiates and he's calling he's in
reference to over the past few weeks you
know I talked about I think in my libido
gets in the way of my livelihood of my
desire to work and to be creative and I
thought and I've all of long thought not
just voiced it recently that if I were
to eliminate my weenie and scrotum and
whatever is in my scrotum nuts and more
there's more in your nuts than just nuts
in their they don't tell you whatever
else is in there but there's extra in
there
but if I were to you know take that off
of my body have it removed and mailed
off to another country where they could
even use it as a delectable as a meal
for people that are starving or as just
something for science if they need to
you know I've thought that that would be
better you stand to be carrying this
meal around between my legs but anyway
this is a Clinton on opiates or has been
on opiates and he's talking about it
here we go
but I got a little experience with that
I was on the möbius for a while one
thing that those do is they just take
away your sex drive entirely and you
know in the beginning that was great was
very focused I'm a musician
help me books a lot of my career is
musical Clinton onward and on that art
form but
thing is men that focus it turns into
looking different because your balls
part of your heart you need your heart
to make art okay we got Clinton opiates
talking about balls cutting them off in
New York you need your heart to make art
this is getting a little bit dr. Seuss
II but I'm riding your vibe let's finish
it out here and if you're just going
straight out of the brain you know and
there's no there's no semen flowing in
those thoughts then uh it's going to be
obvious and you're going to come to a
point where you just don't feel inspired
so I know it seems like something that's
just in the way and something that's
annoying but you just got to learn to
deal with it and control it or whatever
do the best you can Thank You Clinton I
appreciate the call man you know
sometimes I think I need this I need
people to fortify when I'm you know not
thinking the best thoughts for myself
because you know this is the second
caller maybe the 31 we've had about you
know me not want to donate part of my
body or crotch to you know to get rid of
my libido and your take on it is
appreciated man that so you're saying
that that you eliminated your sex drive
using opiates long-term use or semi
long-term use and at first it was good
because it helped you focus on your
music but then it got bad because it
killed your libido so much that you
couldn't that wasn't part of your art
your manliness or your vibe you know
your nut your nut stream and that's
that's valid man I mean I guess maybe
you're right maybe if I didn't have a I
could start to feel more effeminate or
just emasculated which would just be
feeling the loss of a masculinity and
not even feeling effeminate really just
feeling the loss of my manhood maybe
that would really bring me down as a
person you know yeah my art might not
have a direction it was coming from it
might not be coming from a man's
direction so those are good points man
you know and I appreciate that
you know maybe it's just some stuff I'm
going through where I just you know I'm
trying to
find excuses for not getting my work
done and I blame some of those things on
the fact that you know sometimes I have
a libido that you know I want to look at
the paperwork but my libido wants to
look at that ass you know or or be a
part of some tits that's on the internet
you know we're be looking at some of
these ladies that's showing their bung
bung holes or you know being wild
you know people that's trying to show
you they're you know just show you all
their ideas you know show you all their
ideas that they keep in their pants and
sometimes I think you know that that
just distracts me and but I appreciate
it man I appreciate you thinking about
it and I appreciate you you know having
that vote of confidence and and and I
appreciate you you know it sounds like
the opiates are part of your past so I
appreciate you getting through that and
good luck with that man I hope that
keeps going well and good luck with your
music man all right so that's so that's
that maybe we keep the nuts you know and
maybe I just get over that hump you know
I think maybe there's something I could
talk to a therapist about why you why
even feel that way why I didn't feel
that that desire let's take another call
here right up mr. Steele this is a boy
Travis a boy
Travis now I knew a boy brought up named
Ravus and it was supposed to be Travis
but they didn't write all the letters on
the certificate when he was born and he
was Ravus but this is Travis take it
away Travis calling from Portland Oregon
cauldron envelop some crazy bus ride
crazy bus rides now I'm going to stop
you right there because I've had some
you know I used to work on a soybean
cotton and corn farm along the
Mississippi Louisiana border right along
the Mississippi River of their Vidalia
water-proof arity home of Jerry Lee
Lewis and Natchez all in that area was
my good friends sister's family farm and
and I and that's where I met slack
Ronnie that almost cut off my leg
- if you want to go back and listen to
that story but but I noticed when I was
over there that um that uh [ __ ] dude
what are we even talking about god I
think I just got a damn cinnamon in my
brain in the shower the water's been
kind of dirty let's hear this one more
time dude
a bus rides so do when I would bus ride
I would ride from down there in
Louisiana where I lived up to the farm
to work and on that bus man they always
had a lot of people here's here's who's
on the bus children that are going
between poor parents a lot of times on
the bus like a parent is like okay I'll
send them to you at your weekend or your
week or your summer with them here yeah
here you go poor people's a lot of
poverty on the bus and then people that
just got out of prison jail also a lot
of like church groups and stuff that are
trying to save money things like that
long-distance travelers are trying to
save money so that's kind of your
conglomerate you have on there
you always have an angry driver who is
it's often a black man or woman you know
and you can somebody can go to bat with
me on that if they want some time trying
to be racist but I won't be
statistically accurate
okay I've ridden on probably a hundred
and eight hounds a hundred and eight
times it was a kind of a black Hardiman
or black hearty woman one time we
stopped by a man's family reunion for
about 45 minutes stood on the way there
and everybody got out and some people
were pissed and some people just smoked
cigarettes and just stayed out of the
heat but I've been on those buses man
and a lot of times they'll have a
homosexual gentleman on those passing
you notes you know they have a girl
who's you know selling hats or some
[ __ ]
everybody's asking for money I mean
everybody who walks to the back to go to
the bathrooms asking for money and you
really are just surviving it's basically
like it's like Survivor that game show
but it's on a bus and you paid for the
experience and you can also find me on
Sunday night I will troll the Greyhound
bus help Twitter feed and I'll retweet
some tweets out of that and it gets
pretty wild but I had a man on there
take me behind the building said he was
selling our
work and he was showing out his cop I
had another man on there we threatened a
woman said he was sick of everything
poured a bunch of cocaine into the
barrel of a gun
got off the bus said he was going to go
shoot himself right in the nose
what else do we have on there dude I had
some other fellows that sat next to me
try to get wild I kissed a young black
gal african-american woman on the on a
train one time on a bus one time a road
train and and that's pretty much it
doesn't sell my stories for now
but let's hear yours let's take it away
one more time I was seeking a bus from
Sacramento that's going to pull in
Greyhound of course anytime anything on
Greyhound you never know what's going to
happen really amen brother
onward so you guys work if this guy and
I'm growing a lot of blood form turned
out to be a piece of [ __ ] so I end up
taking about a pound and a half but
copping yo Brett huh copying your rents
worth long word sitting in my bag to
case bottom my suitcase no problems no
no canines nothing so we got no problems
we got about a pound and a half of weed
on a Greyhound bus leaving a job where
you didn't feel like you were
appreciated
let's keep its adding go so the ride was
smooth but I was talking to do this
right before we develop the bus period
talking about bud or whatever some get
on the bus we're talking this and that I
can't man I got a pipe nobody you know I
hid in the bathroom little prick like
you know what that smell what they smell
it he's like nah man Wow so let me tell
you a Greyhound bus first of all is like
a bathroom so if you go to the bathroom
on a Greyhound bus you're going double
bathroom bro that's double I mean that's
like hiding in the throat of the devil
and then choosing - ah - to snuggle up
inside of his voice box you feel me
let's keep this savvy go so our hands
into mere afterlife then then or
something on going to the bathroom and
so Dan left plate
the zoo game um let's play so he heating
you with that griddle he trying to put
you on that griddle you know he kinda
have you grow yourself what you do here
look here it I was kind of tripping out
let go let us do some I wheat I hit the
pipe and okay so you hit the pipe anyway
bro look did I respect it you know
you're out there in the game you got a
you know if they put you in the game
sometime you got to dribble the ball you
know so you're on a ground but here's my
question is you had a pound and a half a
weed hidden you know they gave you the
mass pipe do you have to hit can you
just smoked a little bit of that weed
that's that's kind of what's wild to me
about it but let's hear it up sorry go
on
I was kind of tripping as I go let's do
some of my weed I hit the pipe and long
story short gonna sleep the whole damn
ride and this - we've already just gone
back for crazy store isn't anyways man I
know it is pretty cool experience you
know okay
so there you go that was a bus
experience that he had on navigating the
nation's roadways via bus via autobus
and I wonder man it's you know you get
that you know it's one thing that's
funny and I'm going to relate to you
here and I appreciate the call man I do
appreciate you calling and sharing I've
never been on the methamphetamines or
even taking a surprise hit of it I have
a family member who smokes some meth one
time and went rock climbing and actually
ended up climbing their way up to a
nudist colony where she and her
boyfriend stayed up there and had lunch
with the locals but that was out in
Arizona outside of Tucson I believe
anyhow yeah menu on the Greyhound bus
and sometimes what I notice is when
you're it when you're you got to fit in
with your environment okay because say
you sit there with the dude right and
I'm a picture this dude probably white
dude dice on his neck tatted dice you
know probably got a bunch of you know
like tennis shoes like wrapped around
his neck hanging off the laces you know
got six bandanas got a bandana on each
kneecap
you know I mean even
he probably has knee even his kneecaps
Turin rival gangs you know so he just he
probably walk all bowlegged because his
knees can't get alone you know you got
some kind of Jordans you know or double
Jordans you know he gots a tall you know
he's all clipped up and gripped up and I
can see that you know and if you're in
that environment some of you if you sit
next to that guy on the bus you have to
you got to play that game because if you
play them too good for this I'm better
than this I can't relate that's when
[ __ ] gets weird that's when the dudes
like I'm gonna rob this guy you know and
that I think is a you know that's a lot
of what you see a lot of in the world
today in America is that people can't
relate to each other because people want
to sit next to each other on that bus
you know some people to be up in first
class and pretend they know what's going
on in coach you know or vice versa or
vice versa and so I think was you're on
the ground bus you got to get in some
times where you don't fit in because you
got to get to where you're going that
you know sometimes the the means justify
the end you know or the end justifies
the means I don't know what it is bro I
might be metaphorically dyslexic but but
that's real man and I respected dude you
were out there and you stayed the course
and you got done what you had to do when
you got where you had to go and you call
it an experience and that's the thing
you know I be on the greyhound sometimes
and if then boys started hitting on me
some sugar boys I'll let them hit I
stand in the batter's box ok if they
hitting on me I'll stand in the batter's
box because the last thing I want is to
get laced up on some kind of drug and
the next thing you know I met some you
know bus stop and looking at artwork and
I get banged up by a couple of dudes I
don't know you know and that's the kind
of stuff that happens sometimes you have
to fit in you have to get in where you
don't fit in
you know and and uh and so I applaud you
man you know obviously you know the
smoke in the meth not a good idea
doesn't sound like you're on it you know
and I would hope that you're not but you
know it doesn't sound like you had a
pound and a half of weed and you know
just a mess showed up so you opted for
that but whatever you fit in where you
had to fit in because it probably been
scary as hell sleeping all night makes
the old dude and you don't know what
he's thinking about because one out of
70 people on the greyhound just got out
of prison dude prison I'm not talking
about you know down the street lockup
I'm talking about one of these prison
that pick you they pick them up in a
rural town and then they're on the bus
some of the first people they ever see
are on a Greyhound bus you know I mean I
think every Greyhound bus you have to
pull in to wherever they produce the
show Forensic Files and get tested if we
could solve half of the nation's murders
right there
thank you for going hound let's hit this
next call right here and pop-pop
hey yo this is Trevor from California
again just I got cut off because I was
rambling too much in that last message
but I think I cut off right where the
first story of the sauna interaction so
again I was sitting in the sauna reading
my books and a guy comes an older guy
comes in okay this is Trevor Trevor
Trevor had actually called him last week
about nationalism we had a discussion
about that and then he'd said that some
men had really approached him at some
saunas at different times you know and
Trevor believe Trevor believes in one
world and a you know globalization in
you know the fact that you know we
should you know and I'm paraphrasing
here Trevor and this is one of the
problems of not having a back-and-forth
call ability which we are trying to get
I promise you I'm trying to get it but
one of the problems of not having that
is that I have to paraphrase sometimes
but Trevor uh you know believes in that
one world that globalization the fact
that we can all get along together but I
asked him he had mentioned that he had
been in some saunas where men was
getting uh general
we're men was you know letting their own
nature get you know letting their own
natures start to flourish in front of
him and so I want to hear a little bit
more about that so let's go um reading
my books and a guy comes in older guy
comes in and just in the peripheral and
corner of the eye a type stuff and
anyway so I'm sitting there reading my
book the guy comes in I'm just reading
normally and then I hear a little bit of
commotion over there I look over and the
guy's basically jacking it in the corner
so this man's jerking it out this man's
uh you know what I'm saying dust in that
chair leg if you will in the corner of
this sauna all right onward I just right
right in front of me and I'm sitting
there reading book and and I say to the
guy what are you doing and the guy looks
up looks up at me
oh so you played the old I don't know
card deal what are you doing you know
let's go and literally responds I
thought you just got to stop but he
doesn't really stop but he says it's
okay
and I said no it's not and I walked out
and Wow so you said he said it's okay
you said no it's not it's really kind of
great as it sounds like an after school
one of those videos you see of how what
to do if somebody's jerking off in the
sauna you know it needs to do act outs
to in art and our town they didn't have
a lot of the video so they would bring
this um sexual deviants group from the
local jail when I was young and they
would act out different scenarios and
teach you how to say no and how to not
let somebody you know beat you up or
molest you or something like that
you know and they would do like a
performance art of it pretty wild
because you had these men who were in
their 40s and 50s dressed up like young
kids and stuff but I guess it was
effective I don't even know but anyhow
this man was spraying out or you know or
finding you know searching himself for
nut via his pleasure zones and you you
didn't want it you didn't want it he
called him out on it and then what
happened let's hear more yeah I just
told the owner
the thought of that hate others there's
a dude just kind of exposing himself and
being inappropriate okay so I'll just
stop you there so you ratted him out you
know
you ratted him out and I get it it's a
sauna you're paying to be there some
dudes you know some dudes are peeking
somebody's peeking on his uh you know
somebody's peaking peaking out with his
own seed you know some dudes playing
lighthouse with his body making
lighthouse out of his crotch then yeah I
get it man and you know to rat them out
to those to the to the manager you know
I think you have to really kind of maybe
let him learn his lesson in there and
somebody's going to teach him that
that's not appropriate
sometimes that's what those people need
to learn because what does the man do
when you go tell the YMCA director he
throws him out and then he this man goes
jerky
captain jerko goes back to his car and
just puts another X on a building where
he's not allowed to jerk off okay
well what happens Trevor when he gets
all the X's filled in on his little
jerk-off bingo card you know when it's
him when he hits that blackout then the
only space left to jerk off is outdoors
and that's when it you know that's when
I think it escalates and anything can be
possible you know so maybe should have
taught that dude you know try to teach
them a little something you know what
I'm saying and I don't know how you do
that you could have used like some you
know some mind tricks or really put set
him straight
but maybe you should have taught them a
little lesson you know I appreciate you
sharing the call though to take it back
to a globalization now Trevor you got to
think about this in a global in a note
if we just let everybody in all the time
everybody going to be jerking off in
your sauna imagine you're in your sauna
bro you trying to read a book you know
you having them luxuries I call that
luxuries man when you're in a homemade
hot room you know when you got your own
little private Tahiti you know when you
got a
a 15 square-foot Tahiti inside of a gym
and you're reading a book novella and up
and they got another man next to you
jerking off that you don't know I mean
that that's a luxury so to think that
that's occurring man we go to
globalization where everybody's gonna be
doing that you can have people banging
on the door outside of that who want a
piece of your luxury and you know I
think that's one thing about that that
we didn't get to discuss and I'd love to
discuss it in a few try no this is a
one-sided discussion I'm not trying to
preach at your or judge or make fun of
your Trevor I appreciate you calling but
we got to be willing to share before we
before you know we got it if we're going
to care we got to share you know we're
going to care we got a shared it and are
we really willing to share are the
comfortable really willing to share I
don't know I don't know man but I
appreciate that call man I appreciate
that call 100 percent all right let's
get a little bit of diversification this
evening in crack into this twisted
nutshell right here that just fell off
the the world branch into our ear your
earth you feel me
let's catch this nut dude let's catch
this nut in our ears you know what I'm
saying let's listen to the sweet skeet
sounds of this young lady right here
hitting the hotline thank you
hey Theo its Christie calling from
Raleigh North Carolina and my husband I
love your show
we can through it as often as we can
okay we got prissy or Chrissy I couldn't
hear what which one fully but prissy or
Chrissy thank you guys for hitting
hotline let's go and I really appreciate
how you talk a lot and have mentioned in
the past time about maturing emotionally
and the importance of really like
healing relationship and drinks and
relationships with other people
well yes certainly I appreciate you
saying that you know I bring it up a
good bit I'm trying to learn you know
and I often don't think I'm doing a good
job but but I am trying you know I'm
making an effort
I feel like it's important let's keep
going that's like exactly what my
husband and I have is going through we
just kind of hit a point where we had to
up our level of communication and stop
making so many assumptions about why the
other one was doing or saying what they
were doing it can really strip down to
the core love that's between us and to
all our communication in order to better
understand one another and in drop
there's a function yeah I mean when
people get too close sometimes they it's
weird you get too close you spend too
much time together and you are you
almost get too used to each other in a
way where if anything feels a little bit
off then that becomes an issue where
normally if you don't spending too much
time together then you know if
something's a little off you you don't
matter it doesn't matter as much because
you still appreciate it because you're
still you're just happy to be around the
person so sometimes that can be just a
matter of a length of time I think but
also you're talking to a guy who you
know hasn't been in a committed
relationship successfully what are what
I consider success you know haven't been
really honest in any committed
relationship I don't think I've been in
and I don't think I've allowed myself
really to be in the mid a lot of times
wholeheartedly onward so my question to
you is this those through this
communication
my husband has and I have both agreed to
kind of call each other out one thing to
just point out where we might be making
assumptions about the other person or
making reaction or saying or doing
things that aren't necessarily kind or
loving as a result of misunderstanding
one another so kind of like pointing out
each other shortcomings and we both
agreed to do this for one another
however when I try to do this for my
husband in the moment he really doesn't
want to hear it
can't he fight against it and almost
make this beam light I'm the one that's
being unkind when all that I'm doing is
showing him what he has showed him
Wow first of all this sounds like it
should be recorded and put on
to the web for other people to enjoy to
people agreeing to expose each other
shortcomings at the moment of the at the
moment that those shortcomings come to a
head at the moment those shortcomings
bubble to the top of the pot sounds
extremely dangerous
this sounds North Korean this sounds
like a dumpster fire if you will dude
this sounds like to cats you know uh
just ripping each other's hair out you
know in a dumpster
you know while another man is outside of
the dumpster filling the dumpster up
with water and gasoline this just sounds
like a danger where danger lurks like
say if somebody's like hey come over
here and I'm like what's over there
they're like danger lurks over here and
then I get over there I would see you
guys doing this that's what this seems
like to me I'm going to hear you out
here thanks for the call
onward which I'll talk about moment he's
open hearing about but in the moment
which is where we're trying to you know
knit things in the bond a little bit
he just doesn't doesn't really want to
hear it he takes it as me be critical or
putting him down or say something rude
or mean to him are harsh it's just hard
for him to hear it when I'm not okay and
I'll stop it right there and I
appreciate the call I mean it's a real
thing it's like you guys are trying to
you know solve some of your relationship
issues by when things arise that you
already have agreed bug each other bug
you to bring it up to hit that hit that
that button right then you know but it
sounds like that just can't I don't know
how that can read it sounds like it's
just going to lead to an endless world
of arguing and discussing and it sounds
like what you guys want to do is love
each other better love each other the
best you can so I think what you got to
do is just just love each other and not
bring those things up you know and and
they shouldn't be faster if those things
are faster inside of you in the end it's
more you I think than it is or its you
or its hammer T it's you it's you guys
as individuals and it is as a
relationship
you know because anytime you start
saying this person should do this this
person should do that usually you have
to adjust what your expectations are you
know I mean I think and I know you can
of course you can expect a great deal
out of your out of your significant
other your spouse you know the one
that's catching your spread you know at
night but but you you can't you can't
expect things to be you know you can't
expect to get there by nitpicking I
don't think and even if the nitpicks are
serious I think you just got to love
each other thing she's got to love the
balls off of each other you know I dated
a girl for a while had a beard one time
she had kind of a light beard and this
burned me sometimes you know but I just
had to see past the love I couldn't you
know every time I caught an angle of the
light and it was hitting that beard I
couldn't you know get angry at her you
know or call her Wayne Newton you know I
couldn't do that kind of stuff for color
you know Travis Tritt or color wheel or
Walker jr. you know I just had to just
accept the little bit of beard that I
was seeing at that angle when the light
hit her face and so it's a lot of it's
about acceptance you know whether you're
in a relationship or married or whether
you dating somebody that has a light
beard you just have to accept it because
if every time that beard starts showing
up in your relationship you try to shave
it or you try to tell them hey I see
your beard shave it that's uncomfortable
it's going to get weird it's never going
to end because that hair that's never
going to stop growing so the best thing
you can do is just love them and say hey
hey world I'm dating this slightly
surprised bearded a [ __ ] right
here and I appreciate the call thank you
very much for calling in god bless happy
to have you guys on this past weekend
baby all right man what else can we hit
here I think I got one
another caller that hit the hotline let
me see what we got here all right
yovan I do a man who's Richard over ends
is Richard right here go ahead Richard
over in st. Louis Missouri
Oh st. Louis Richard under the arches
they call them the old arch Richard old
back support Richard right here let's
hit it Richard go on sweatin melting
over here is hot hey I love the podcast
never miss an episode I got to wonder
and though you never mentioned food I
don't think I've ever heard you mention
any kind of food you eat any kind of
food you like any kind of food you don't
like you know Sunday's I'm watching a
podcast I'm like dang this do you
probably ain't nothing but chili dogs
all day long then other days I'm like
maybe looks like he had a nice salad so
some refreshing beverages or you know
kind of strange but I I was just getting
ready to dinner and I'm not sure what to
eat and I thought one would feel Bonnie
anyways men love podcasts I tell
everybody I know about it it's great man
awesome
so I do love you too Richard and that is
uh I guess we can call them a restaurant
Richard right there who wants to know
what I'm eating what do I eat you know
at first I was just going to be like man
Richard that is just the weirdest [ __ ]
ever that you care what I eat you know I
was like this guy's a creep you know
this guy is someone who is the you know
one of those calorie watchers you know
you know who watches what you eat and
writes it down on a notepad who's
sitting in the distance why are you
trying to eat but now I think about it
and it kind of felt pretty good that you
cared man I appreciate you caring dude
you know I do what do I eat man you know
I do I I have a lot of smoothies because
I don't really like to eat that much I
get a little bored over time of eating
you know I work a lot and I'm running
around a lot out here in Los Angeles and
so it's hard to know them to come back
home all the time because of traffic so
you don't really get that that time too
all the time your home-cooked meals I
like small oranges those little oranges
cuties tangerines tangelos different
types what do I like I like a banana
sometimes I like apples with peanut
butter you know sometimes I get a damn
Capri Sun you know outside of that I
like water you know some I'm gonna have
me some ice cream I'm a little
lactose-intolerant so I'll hang with the
sherbet but I like different types of
meats and brisket some fish I like a
flaky fish something white wha-hoo my
money you know every every now and then
maybe once every two or three weeks I'll
be a little bit of sushi ugly heavy on
the wasabi with a lighter soy sauce that
low-sodium if you're still rocking high
sodium soy sauce do that's that like I
mean that's the damn oxycodone of Japan
right there get the green top okay go
light sodium now when I'm at home in
Louisiana I have whatever they got you
know what I'm saying I'll let somebody
just stick a dip of catfish in a vat of
mayonnaise and just beat me in the back
of the throat with it because I like to
have them Louisiana snacks I like
different vegetables I'll eat a salad
sometimes with no dressing on it just
plain I like it like that also I don't
need a lot of cheese I like cheese but I
know that if I like it a lot something's
wrong you know because then I just heat
cheese you know sometime I just wish I
could just have cookies with cheese on
them but you can't have that it's not
good for you you know I like avocado
when I was young my daddy used to eat
avocados you'd cut them in half take the
pit out fill each half with mayonnaise
and and eat those with a spoon needed
out of the Rhine and I remember sometime
I'd sneak over there by him and he'd
give me a little mouthful of that Ivo
Mayo and that was a good time reminds me
of being young I'm going to come to
desserts I like coconut cake like Boston
cream pie like coconut cream pie
I like a creme brulee boy you could find
me in the desert club okay sugar
Buster's is for mother all right I don't
mind a chocolate pudding dude you know
got to go cake I usually like to go a
German chocolate I like a king cake
around the holidays it's a Louisiana
tradition and I like that a creme brulee
and I like that bread pudding any type
of bread pudding I don't care you got
raisins in it dude I'll be in it and
that's what I like I appreciate you
calling appreciate everybody calling
this week man we're going to hit the hot
line imma get you guys out of here it's
been a good time hit the hot line man
let me know what you guys want to talk
about what you guys think what else what
can we talk about for next week man it's
August you know it's almost August I'm
going to be in Montreal next weekend we
can talk about the Canadians if you want
you got some thoughts on the Canadians
we can talk about summertime traditions
is your family have a unique summertime
tradition we could talk about you know
we talked about the bus and being on
drugs and you know that man trying to
show me his artwork around the side of
the building and maybe if somebody's
ever surprised you you thought you as
maybe getting a hit off of a pipe or hit
off of a dime sack and then they
surprise you with some breasts or some
wiener you know we can talk about that
if some fellas are out there having
tough times with some manhood stuff
maybe get back into some manhood I'd
love to do that you know what's going on
to me you guys you know how you feeling
what are you struggling with you
struggling with drugs you struggling
with alcohol you struggling with women
you know just share it man sometime you
got to let it out set it on somebody
else's shoulders I got two of them right
here if you need them and that's it man
I just hit one year sober you know I'll
talk about that that much because I
don't know if I will be that forever but
for the time being it's um you know it's
a part of my life I just don't want you
know it doesn't define me you know I
don't know what that is in my life but
for right now you know it's something
that's working for me if that feels good
but I don't care if you are you are not
I'm not here to judge you Madame is
trying to be one of you you know I don't
have to be right
I hope not anyway I'm going to start
feeling like I have to that's what I
know something's wrong with me but I
appreciate you guys call a man I love
you and and this is a good man and this
this has been this past week and I'll
see you guys next Monday
thank you very much take us out
[Music]
elebrate Levin celebrate is a ring no
that's who we're gonna die I stopped
some fun wow real god it's a Spencer
Jacob grab and be good to yourselves man
let's try that on let's stick together
stick it out we got this man
be good to yourselves I bet you deserve
it